- How about you do surgery over here,
now this surgeon over there, and now this
surgeon.
- You guys have bombarded my
comment section saying I should check
out Michael Reeves video of how he built
a surgical robot, we're
going to react to it
and throughout this video I'm going to be
answering some frequently asked
questions about the da Vinci robot.
Da Vinci Surgical System is the most
advanced streamlined surgical experience
for minimally invasive surgery
available in the world today
- I could build that
(dramatic music)
hey, how's everyone's
global health crisis going?
- If this guy can build a da Vinci robot,
he's going to get one of these golf
claps from me.
- let me tell you those
da Vinci Surgery robotics rats, are
ripping hospitals off look at this 2
million dollars for one robot they could
spend that on a couple hundred bandages
are like one ambulance ride in the US, we
can build a better surgery robot for a
lot less.
- This sorry sarcasm here is heavy,
but it's true like if you look at an
itemized bill from a hospital, nothing
makes sense a Tylenol dose is $50, a
bandage like he said is a 1000 but
those numbers are so horribly inaccurate
because what the insurance actually ends
up paying to the hospital is a
completely different story.
- [Michael] The biggest flaw in da Vinci's
design is that, it
relies on these clunky slow robotic arms
for movements say you're operating on a
patient's foot, he start screaming out
in pain, you got to get up to his face
smack him a little bit making shut up.
- I don't know if you guys saw my surgery
simulator video but I literally was
smacking my patient around
trying to see if he's awake.
- [Michael] slowly and
they don't have any travel distance.
Instead working about the surgical tools
to a rail system that can move anywhere
of an operating table.
- Time out, I think
the reason the da Vinci robot doesn't
freely move around the patient is
because you want it locked into place
when you're doing a minimally invasive
procedure. You want it done in a specific
area, I mean like millimeters, millimeters
matter, that's actually one of the
selling points of these robotic machines
is, that they have a better range of
motion than the human hand, they also are
more precise,
and when the surgeon
actually looks inside with the camera
they can see 10 extra magnification so
they could be more accurate.
- This is the homing
sequence it figure out the balance
of the machine by measuring the amperage
of the mode on the motors when they stop.
(laughing)
Yeah, you can make it you can make it do
this, maybe not as stable as you'd want it
to be, but yeah it's just a prototype.
- Can you imagine if you're getting
wheeled into a surgery as a patient and
the thing is just shaking all over though,
and the patient's like,
what that, that's what
you're operating on doctor, don't worry
we're just calibrating the x and y axis
you'll be fine, I wouldn't be scared.
- [Michael] it looks
like it's handling small
movements pretty well, y-axis, x
okay, it's not that bad,
it's fine,
it will be fine.
We can probably just go ahead and
make the final version.
- All I'm thinking
in the back of my head is, imagined this
is how the actual da Vinci robot was
created like someone was just sitting,
and they were they were testing it with
10 pound plates from the gym.
- I'm going to turn it on,
oh God, oh boy,
(machine draws sound)
- For me I learned
how to use a new iPhone app, I
get excited. This guy created his own
robot.
- I got this VR hand tracking camera
off of Amazon that works super goddamn
well, so you just take the hand
coordinates from this, pipe him in the
surgery robot and bing-bang-boom.
- Michael we need to connect and we need
to do some kind of surgery simulator
with this kind of VR technology we got
to do something epic like we gotta
perform surgery on a
grape, no, no, no on a
peach
no,
no
on a nut.
- How about you do
surgery over here, now this
surgeon over there, and now this
surgeon!
- Okay this is the most
medically inaccurate part. We don't
just start doing surgeries on different
parts of the body and that's why this
whole concept is horribly flawed to
begin with (laughing), you
didn't need to be able to
operate on all different parts of the
patient at the same time that's why the
da Vinci has all these little arms and
gadgets that move around at different
angles, because the area you want to go
in, then you want to have the flexibility
to move around in that area.
But you don't want to be
in the patient's kidney
and then in the patient's brain the next
second, if you're doing that some shady
stuff is going on.
[Michael] Unlike some other
surgical systems we've
run a gamut of tests to ensure our
machine has power I'm going to stab a
pineapple, mention the operation.
- If you're going to be
operating on a patient,
you want it like to be, if you move your,
your little finger like this, it moves
exactly like that, because if it does
anything more than that you're going be
cutting into an artery, patients not
going to do well,
Insurance is going to go up
for you because you've done malpractice
and it's really a solution or a equation
for disaster what's the term?
That experiment was really fun but also
really dangerous. Michael if you watch
this video please do not ever stick your
hand in where there's a sharp moving
around, sporadically,
back and forth.
I was worried for your
digits, your digits.
Terms of usability in
a hospital setting I'm
going to give it a two. It might do really
great in like the kids lab, when you're
trying to get them interested in the da
Vinci machine but they obviously can't
play on a $2.6 million machine, but
they can play on yours.
Speaking of the da Vinci
machine, I actually saw that
clip that he said of the grape, the
performing surgery, and I see memes
galore of it, but I've never actually
seen the grape video. Is a red grape I'd
preferred green.
look at that lighting system.
(upbeat music)
(music draws sound)
what kind of surgery is this?
Do you think this is like
a prostate, by ah oh!
they're doing a little flap on the grape.
(upbeat music)
Is this in slow motion or is that how
fast the machine moves?
I know minimally invasive
surgery generally takes longer
and the patient has to be under
anesthesia, longer sometimes that could
make certain patients who want minimally
invasive not good candidates if they
can't be under anesthesia for a long
time. I've had patients ruled out for
robotic surgery just 'cause of that.
No, are they skinning the grape?
Oh
that's good.
You know sometimes I do that with my teeth
before I eat the grape.
These machines, the little
robots hands, have such
amazing range of motion, it's better than
our human hands and that's what makes
this super special as a type of
technology, because when you have to go
into tight areas into tight crevices you
need really great range of motion and
remember when you're looking at this
with the naked eye it's hard to see
where the skin begins and the grape ends.
- It's like that, reverse it.
- Where the grape begins
and the skin ends.
So you wouldn't be able
to do this but with
that 10x magnification you can go in and
really see the skin come off, and be
super accurate. Wait so that's it, that's
the whole viral grape video, how did all
the memes start?
L-0-L equals laughing out loud,
T-M-I too much information,
B-R-B equals be right back,
T-T-Y-L talk to you later,
T-D-S-O-A-G, they did surgery on a grape.
I'm going to text my
nephew, let's see, T, I'm
going to do all caps T-D-S-O-A-G.
Oh my nephew incident
(laughing draws sound).
You don't know
what that means bro.
It means they did surgery
on a grape.
He's typing,
mad old.
Did he just say mad? You're mad old,
he just turned 16 he
thinks he's a tough guy
now. Tom Hanks they did surgery on a
grape, my beautiful wife was by my side
throughout the whole surgery, my rock.
This thing does not look like a grape,
this looks like a gummy character.
Nurse you've been in a
coma since 2012, patient
they did, did they finally
do surgery on a grape?
We can't do the surgery.
You're going to die.
I thought I was next in line?
Unfortunately, a grape came
in oh my god that's so funny
I mean it's not funny it's dark but it,
it would never happen.
I want to answer some of
the top questions that I get
from patients when they are either
considering getting robotic surgery or
someone has recommended it to them and
they're afraid.
- [Guest] who does the surgery,
the doctor or the robot?
- The surgeons are controlling
the robotic device a hundred,
a hundred percent.
- [Guest] what are the differences between
robotic surgery and open surgery?
- The difference between
robotic surgery which is considered a
minimally invasive surgery compared to
open, is generally faster recovery times
less bleeding less side-effects patients
actually spend less time in the hospital
as a result, basically you're making
smaller incisions and at times you don't
even need to make incisions obviously
depending where the procedure is.
Now not every patient is
a candidate for robotic
surgery or minimally invasive surgery so
it needs to be discussed on an
individual level, but something to also
keep in mind robotic surgery is really
expensive even when compared to other
minimally invasive surgeries.
- [Guest] Are there
any procedures where robotic
surgery doesn't work?
- There's absolutely
procedures where robotic surgery doesn't
work and we have to tailor that to each
individual patient. So when I have a
patient that comes to me for a surgical
clearance, one of the questions the
surgeons ask is the cardiac status of
the patient, comorbidities, what is the
patient taking medication wise, all of
these things are factored in, in addition
to the type of surgery that needs to be
performed. Some surgeries just fare
better as open surgeries than minimally
invasive.
- [Guest] Can any doctor or surgeon use a
DaVinci machine?
Any doctor or surgeon that's trained on a
DaVinci machine can use it, but you do
need that level of training, you can't
just come on and start using it like,
Michael Reeves, where you can come on and
figure out how it works. No it's more
complicated that, you absolutely need to
be trained and certified.
- [Guest] We'll robotic
surgical systems make doctors obsolete?
Doctors are humans, humans need to treat
humans, while there's certain things that
we can allow the AI to do. Help us
better identify certain things on
radiographic images, help us find
information faster, they cannot replace
the mandatory human connection when
treating a patient.
- [Guest] Are the results of
surgeries conducted with
da Vinci worth the cost?
- This is one of the most
important questions and why robotic
surgery is actually a
hotly contested subject.
Remember you have two different
options for minimally invasive
laparoscopic and robotic, robotic at
times can be really expensive and not
worth the benefit so where do we go from
here, ideally we want to lower the cost
of these robotic surgeries so that they
can replace laparoscopic procedures, but
not cost the healthcare system something
like, 3 to 5 billion dollars a year.
Also there are certain things that
can be happening in the near future,
where we can improve these systems and
perhaps get the evidence to show that
they're better than the laparoscopic
minimally invasive surgery, we'll see.
(phone beeping)
- [On Phone] Doctor!
- Yo, they did surgery on a grape
- [On Phone] What does that even mean?
- No they did surgery on
a grape, that's why I sent
you the acronym.
- [On phone] They did surgery on a grape,
I still don't get it.
- In 2018, they did surgery
on a grape.
- [On Phone] In 2018, they
did surgery on a grape.
- Yeah
- [On Phone] I don't get it bro.
- What do you mean.
- [On phone] (phone draws
sound), does that mean anything
to you there, performing
surgery on a grape.
Is it something to do with circumcising?
(laughing)
- What,
my latest memes videos
absolutely hilarious
it was quite nutty you'll get what I
mean once you click on it or check out
me playing minecraft.
I actually reviewed some Hospital builds
at other Minecrafters, mine
crafting gamers have created. Click here
for that one, and as always stay happy
and healthy which one
you're clicking though.
(upbeat music)